I think interpretation is a fascinating
area and I'm not even quite sure what
interpretation is I thought a lot about
what it means to interpret music and to
interpret anything for that matter
literature or art visual arts paintings
I think it's absolutely essential to
stay true to the to the intentions of
the composer but what that means is very
complicated and very nuanced because
there's no composer I think who's worth
his or her salt who who would who would
want his piece played without personal
involvement from the performer the piece
after all doesn't come to life until it
is played or interpreted if you will and
what I try to do is make the music as
honest as possible and as natural as
possible that doesn't mean I keep myself
out of the proceedings that would be
impossible some music requires absolute
commitment and complete force of
personality or it's not being true to
the composer so how you how you decide
how a piece goes has to be based on your
personal response but motivated by what
is offered to you on the page there
there is the possibility with living
composers to ask them what they actually
wanted when they wrote something down
but at the risk of being provocative or
sounding if I don't care what they think
I don't I don't necessarily believe that
composers are the best it's that they
know best how a piece should be
performed I actually am very interested
in what is written down on the page
because that is a necessarily limited
language the notations the
black-and-white scrawls that that you
see on the page you know when the
composer decides to write a tempo
marking a metronome marking how fast
they feel the piece should go
it's it's almost impossible to realize
that exactly it's a suggestion but it's
a suggestion you should take seriously
and they're there times where I will
consciously ignore well ignore is not
the word but I won't do exactly the the
metronome marking for various reasons
because the acoustic in the particular
hall I might be playing in as is such
that for example a fast tempo if we do
the actual tempo marking that date that
the the composer writes down it would
sound mushy because there's too much
reverberation in the hall or or the
players themselves you know maybe you
can get more beautiful playing that I
think somehow it be more true to the
intentions of the composer by altering
something we're asking for more sound or
less sound notation as i said is
necessarily limited and I think that's
the beauty of interpretation is that you
have to take the notation and make it
your own and so when I study a piece I
try to work with it until I get to the
point where if I open the page the score
to any page I get an immediate and
visceral response that this is how the
music goes and that means that I've made
choices but finally in a strange way my
personality has nothing to do with it of
course in the actual performance you
have to be engaged you have to be
involved you have to be able to commit
yourself to something you have to be
able to go for something but i think
that there's the mistaken idea people
talk about oh I like the interpretation
I think often when people talk about
interpretation in that way what they're
looking for is a quirky decision
something that that has obviously been
worked out and for me as soon as i'm
aware of a decision having been made in
a performance there's something
intrinsically wrong already the premise
is wrong i think that the most
interesting and the most real and most
profound interpretations don't sound
like interpretations necessarily they
just sound right